there is a future activity so a program
running in in fall this year's the next
semester and it's on blockchains and and
you know where else that sort of
technology can be applied you know it's
nice yet associated problems and main
organizer for that program is yes hi
everybody so this program is organized
with a elements and Sun
yeah I'll collide I fell paths and my
quad fish so the official title is
proofs consensus and centralized into
society though I guess between friends
we can call it the blockchain program so
actually the title is informative in the
sense that it directly relates to three
scientific themes that we'll be thinking
about during your program you can think
about them as pillars one of them is the
cryptographic proofs
the other one is large-scale consensus
and the last one is the use of these
tools to deriving applications for the
centralizing society now this these
scientific themes actually cover a
rather broad a range of topics in
computer science and beyond all the way
from complexity a cryptography in
programming languages to distributed
algorithms game theory and also beyond
computer science a questions in
economics law and ethics so let me tell
you just a little about a about some of
these themes the first one has to do
with proof systems this is a beautiful
theory that we've developed in computer
science or a past three-day decades and
it's a really powerful lens to solve
many problems in complexity theory
perhaps one of the most compelling use
cases of proof systems is a very direct
one where if you have two parties Alice
and Bob and Alice wishes to convince Bob
of a computational statement then the
two of them can engage in a proof
protocol where Alice plays the role of
the Pooler and Bob Bob that of the
verifier and besides sort of achieving
the properties of proof system we
no today of how to achieve some pretty
amazing properties one of them is that
of delegation of computation where the
where Bob can actually check a
computation exponentially faster than it
takes to conduct the competition itself
there amazing property is zero knowledge
where a sort of proof that attests to
the correctness of computation actually
hides all sort of internal all
information about in so intermediate
states of the computation is actually
this area is a mix of beautiful theory
and applied work there's also strong
industrial interest because crypto have
cryptographic proofs are becoming a
really an essential tool for privacy and
scalability in peer-to-peer systems it's
in fact actually already standardization
efforts to take some of these proof
systems and and sort of make them a
standard tools and a toolkit of
cryptography in the real world and
actually I wanted to mention that
there's actually an event happening in
six weeks at the Berkeley marina and
here's a there's a there's a website for
that here oh and on the on April 13th
will hold that as the Kay day will have
an entire will have several talks
discuss as geology proofs applications
of intersections machine learning and
privacy and yeah so there's a lot of
exciting things happening like in in
this area even beyond the upcoming
semester so anyways so one of the
workshops that the semester will be
dedicated precisely to this to this
pillar will be the first the first
workshop and towards the end of
September
so that's just one team maybe let me
tell you about a another theme I'll just
jump to the third one
so a Simone is an example of an
important societal function you think
about the centralized implementation is
the sort of fiat money where so some
trusted party says you know you know
here I'm issuing tokens you know please
you know trust you know I'm gonna use
them as my sort of authority to
to say that their legal tender and the
Centaurs implementation you can think
about it other cryptocurrencies now
there's some sort of new application
stack that is developing where you know
through distributed Ledger's that are
enabled by cryptographic proofs and
consensus algorithms you can actually
build these stupid applications on top
of it
for example payment systems okay but you
can also ask you know what's the cycle
functions are technically feasible to
achieve via the centroid systems and
which ones are socially desirable and
over the past few years there's been a
lot of work trying to explore how to
achieve other societal functions such as
elections or maybe provide a more secure
supply chains that use many of these
tools okay this is really like you know
so high quality reapplied for a
realizing useful peer-to-peer systems
but because these applications are
ultimately in meant to be used and
actually are being used by sort of
people on society then you're learning
to like you know priests or any sort of
questions an intersection of economics
so law and ethics so you will actually
have an entire it's the last workshop on
of the this program will be dedicated
towards exploring these applications and
also you know sort of study questions
that sort of go outside of computer
science via we have very outward looking
so it's just a short snippet there is a
you know like all the upcoming problems
you can learn more information about it
on things on the website where Sam's
Institute you can see the the visitors
are coming you can read more about each
of the workshops and yeah so it could be
held a disarming fault any questions
[Applause]